en parlant de la syrie vous disais qu'il
fallait discuter à tout le moins avec
avec les terroristes
c'était c'était ce que sous-entend
theetge pas dit qu'il fallait discuter
avec les terroristes j'ai dit que les
chancelleries devrait se mettent en
relation avec le calife al bagdadi qui
est le patron comme chacun sait de
l'état islamique parce que effectivement
suffit juste d'écouter ce que disent les
terroristes quand ils disent qu'ils
interviennent ils disent qu'ils viennent
venger le prophète mais ils viennent
aussi c'est à cause de hollande et de sa
politique
ça a été dit parce que ce qu'on veut
bien entendre cette chose-là dans le
bataclan ça a été dit très clairement
donc ça aurait pu être aussi la
politique de sarkozy puisque c'est la
même
et c'était aussi celle de mitterrand
depuis 1991 j'ai eu juste une parenthèse
a été jacques chirac et de très beaux
discours de villepin à l'onu
mais sinon effectivement on est dans une
logique de guerre nous depuis des années
et le son d'une ville logique de réponse
du faible au fort d'ailleurs le
terrorisme un gamin de 15 ans avec des
bouteilles de gaz et une voiture peut
aujourd'hui mettre la france à genoux
alors que nous avons l'armé nucléaire
et quand même qu'on réfléchisse à cette
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons c'est à dire que ces gamins ils
écoutent le calife
si le khalife dit allez-y aisément si le
khalife dit on lève le pied on n'y va
pas ils n'iront pas où ils iront moins
peut-être d'autant que se qualifent on
sait comment y accéder puisque ce sont
des pays amis a de la france
actuellement la turquie le qatar
l'arabie saoudite quand il s'agit de
vendre des immeubles autour de l'arc de
triomphe on est très copain avec le
qatar
et quand il s'agit de remettre une
légion d'honneur un prince saoudien et
on est très copain avec l'arabie
saoudite quand il s'agit de 2,2 de
permettre à tous les autres pays qui
sont eux en bonnes relations avec l'état
islamique de continuer d'être dans les
bonnes relations entre états islamiques
nous on est aussi en bonne relation avec
ces pays là alors est ce qu'on ne
devrait pas justement penser autrement
les choses estimé qu' il n'y a pas de
bonnes raisons d'aller faire la police
sur la totalité de la planète
pourquoi là au nom de quoi la france
doit-elle faire la police en afghanistan
on va pas la faire en corée du nord
pourquoi pas la faire à cuba va pas la
faire en chine cette clause parce qu'on
sait très bien qu'on va se faire casser
la figure
on fait la police dans des endroits où
on sait très bien qu'on sera supérieur
militairement parce qu il
agit de donner des cautions aux
banquiers aux fabricants d'armes et
qu'on ne touche pas à ces choses-là on
sait très bien que s'il n'y a pas de
guerre les marchands d'armes d'un peu
d'argent
là évidemment si vous faites exploser
des bombes si vous avez des avions qui
eux-mêmes explose si vous avez du
matériel militaire qui est qu'ils y
aient détruit et qu'il faut transformer
qu'il faut remplacer savait faire la
fortune des marchands d'armes donc des
banquiers donc de tout l'argent sale de
la planète donc on sait très bien que
c'est ça qui se trouve derrière la
guerre est derrière les guerres et que
c'est pas du tout les droits de l'homme
droits de l'homme c'est juste de la mpt
la façade c'est juste pour pour
embobiner le téléspectateur ou
l'auditeur qui va croire
qu'effectivement on s'en va là bas parce
qu'il faut que la démocratie triomphe et
qu'il faut en finir avec un dictateur je
rappelle quand même et tous les français
s'en souviendront que bachar el assad
était tellement notre ennemi qu'il a
assisté au défilé du 14 juillet que les
des troupes syriennes étaient sur les
champs-elysées et qu'il était à côté du
président de la république que kadhafi
menace est tellement les intérêts de la
france qui l'ont lu a permis d'installer
sa tente dans un bâtiment de la ddt de
la république et qu'il a été reçu par le
président de la république que saddam
hussein était tellement notre ennemi est
menacée tellement la france quand
vivront des centrales nucléaires et
qu'il faisait fi nancer même les
campagnes de tel ou tel président de la
république doit être abandonnée où on
peut pas être complètement crétin si
vraiment l'irak la syrie la libye c'est
présenter des dangers pour la france en
terme de terrorisme pourquoi étions-nous
des amis avec eux pendant si longtemps
et ce qui est étonnant c'est que ces
amitiés là ne semblait moins choquant
que ça semblait moins choquant que
lorsque vous dites que on peut discuter
avec eux avec ces gens là c'est étrange
oui les ce qu'est ce qui a changé le
matraquage médiatique qui est qui qui
nous fait savoir que ce sont des
barbares et que nous on est des gentils
oui oui ce sont des barbares mais on est
des barbares aussi nous on n'est pas des
barbares de la même manière mais je veux
dire que quand on quand on balance des
bombes sur des villages et qu'on détruit
la totalité du village qu'on aura
peut-être tué trois terroristes monroe
situé 50 personnes qui ne sont pas des
terroristes des enfants des femmes des
femmes enceintes des vieillards des gens
qui c'est qui qui qui qui n'ont rien à
faire d'être time bomb pas talibans qui
sont juste des paysans
gratouille un peu la terre pour essayer
de survivre et qu'on a tué il ya aucune
image de ses combats que nous menons
partout et nous détruisons suffisamment
de gens pour que quelqu'un qui soit
extrêmement sérieux et finit par nous
dire que de 91 à aujourd'hui
ces gars là ont généré 4 millions de
morts notre politique étrangère a généré
4 millions de morts parmi les peuples
musulmans c'est pareil 1,4 million de
morts c'est pas rien ces gens-là
répondent aujourd'hui comme ils
répondent et on dire regardez comme ils
sont barbares mais on n'est pas barbare
nous avoir contribué à la destruction de
quatre millions de personnes mais pas
barbare nous on est des boues puis ils
sont des méchants et c'est donc je dis
juste
arrêtons de penser en termes de bons et
de méchants de barbares et de civiliser
de gens qui nous attaque
alors qu'on aura rien fait tu dis juste
prenons un peu de hauteur faisant de la
géopolitique faisons un petit peu
d'histoire essayons de savoir pourquoi
on en est arrivé là pourquoi des gamins
de 15 ans aujourd'hui sont capables avec
des couteaux de cuisine de semer la
terreur en france où ou avons nous
commis une erreur je dis juste question
que chacun réponde si j'ai tort que
chacun se fasse à lui-même la réponse à
cette question si j'ai tort alors d'où
ça vient d'où ça vient ce qui fait que
aujourd'hui il y adeux du terrorisme
dans nos rues a bien sûr que
on trouvera d'autres réponses à moins
que d'en appeler à satan au mal au péché
originel ou à la barbarie où elle fait
que les musulmans seraient par nature
des barbares et autres bêtises qu'on
entend qu'on entend parfois il faut
faire de la géographie il faut faire de
la géopolitique de la géostratégie de
l'histoire il faut avoir de la mémoire
est juste voir les causes les effets
l'histoire ce n'est jamais que ça de
série de causes et d'effets quand on dit
oui mais le khalife à adolf hitler
bien qu'on parle dit l'air si vous
voulez mais hitler en 1933 c'est presque
trop tard hitler en 1939 c'est bien sûr
trop tard c'est à dire y'a un moment
donné ou quand ils réarme la roue on
sait très bien que c'est à ce moment là
qu'il faut intervenir
donc il ya des moments où effectivement
il faut intervenir mais à des moments en
amont où on peut intervenir autrement
que militairement pour le coup c'est la
diplomatie ce sont les services secrets
et la politique c'est ça c'est pas un
truc de gentils la politique c'est si
vous m'aidez je vous ai nsi vous arrêtez
de m'ennuyer
j'arrête de vous ennuyer 6 etc c'est pas
plus que ça veux ton oui ou non
préserver les français voeu de restaurer
la sécurité en france
si la réponse est oui mais bien sûr
qu'il faut discuter avec les élus ça ne
s'est fait que comme ça les traités de
paix tous les traités de paix ont fait
de telle sorte qu'un jour à la même
table des ennemis se sont rencontrés
pensez vous qu'il était imaginable en
14-18 que la france et l'allemagne
puisse signer ce traité en 39-45 signé
ce traité que nous puissions aujourd'hui
ou même à une époque avoir helmut kohl
et françois mitterrand qui se tenait par
la main at on pu imaginer une seule
seconde avec la haine qui a eu entre la
france et l'allemagne depuis depuis très
longtemps au moins depuis 1870 au moins
on voit bien qu'on a fait la paix avec
nos ennemis d'hier et que les ennemis
d'hier sont devenus nos amis alors je
dis pas que le kali doit devenir notre
ami je dis juste que dans une
perspective de guerre planétaire alors
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est le chef des
armées et qui est le khalife qui est la
possibilité de dire lever le pied sur la
france ou accélérer le mouvement sur la
france il ya peut-être intérêt à avoir
des missions diplomatiques qui nous
permettront de recouvrer un peu de
sécurité parce que quand on nous dit
aujourd'hui la solution c'est de
bombarder et il faut vous faire à l'idée
qu'il ya 20 ans de terrorisme devant
nous je suis pas bien sûr qu'on mérite
d'être prison
quand on n'a que ça à proposer aux
français